- Good afternoon, everybody.
Thank you all for joining this panel
on how to join the quantum workforce.
My name is Florian Carle.
I'm the manager of the
Yale Quantum Institute,
and I'll be one of the
moderators for this panel.
So we are delighted to
continue this series
of talks and panel that
are organized jointly
with the Engineering Workforce Development
of the Center for Quantum
Networks in Arizona
and the Yale Quantum Institute.
This is the third panel in our series
on focusing to prepare
today on how to get a job
or how to put all your
chances on your side
to get a job in academia
and to become an assistant professor
or have any faculty position.
So we wanted to offer this series
of professional development panels,
because building quantum technology
really requires a lot of people
from different backgrounds.
We need physicists, electrical engineers,
computer scientists,
software engineers, chemists.
And it can be a little bit overwhelming
to consider all the options and
all the careers you can have
in the field of quantum
science information.
So today we'll hear from postdocs
and recent faculty members
that will talk about their experience
on what it's like to work
in the field of quantum
and give advice on navigating
the various pathways
to do an academic career.
My colleague Russell Balliet,
who's the assistant director
of the Center for Quantum Networks,
will serve as a moderator.
And I will let him introduce himself.
And talk a little bit
more about the center.
- Yeah. So as Florian
said, I'm Russell Balliet.
I'm the assistant director
for Engineering Workforce Development
for the Center of Quantum Networks.
Who is a new center and just
kind of getting started.
And we'll be laying the foundations
for the quantum networks
and the technologies
as well as looking at
the societal impacts.
And part of the reason
we wanna do this panel is
to help develop the Engineering
Workforce Development
and give you all a
little bit of information
about how you can join
the quantum workforce.
- Thank you.
And then you have on my webcam
some information about the center.
So you can also subscribe
to the YouTube channel
to have all information about the center.
So before we introduce
the rest of the panelists,
I want to walk you through a
little bit of housekeeping.
So we are recording this event
and so it'll be available
in replay if you want.
And then you can use the chat,
the Q and A feature in Zoom.
So at the bottom you should
have two speech bubble.
You can just ask all your questions
and then we'll try to
go through all of them.
So you can have a bit of
understanding on what it will take
to get one of these positions.
Okay. So let's start by
introducing our panelists.
So please, you can feel
free to turn on your webcams
and we'll start with
Linran Fan from the University of Arizona.
- Hi, everyone.
So I'm Linran.
So right now I'm an assistant professor
at College of Optical Sciences
at University of Arizona.
I graduated from Yale University
in Electrical Engineering in 2017.
So it's good to see some
familiar names from YQI.
I spent six years on Hillhouse Avenue.
Yeah. So right now I'm part of
the CQN, the Center for
Quantum Networks center.
So right now my group is working
on quantum with photonics,
and especially related to quantum sensing
and continuous-variable
quantum information.
And right now in my
group I have two postdocs
and six regular students.
So yeah...
And I actually joined the faculty
of University of Arizona in 2018.
So I just passed my three
year mid-review actually.
If you have any questions,
feel free to ask me.
Thank you.
- The three year mid-review is always
a little bit stressful, I guess.
Good luck with that.
- There's more to that.
- Shruti Puri, do you want
to go introduce yourself?
- Yeah. Hi.
My name is Shruti and I'm an assistant,
in the Applied Physics Department at Yale.
I just started last year in
July, so I'm still quite new.
And I'm a theorist.
I work in quantum information theory.
I've always been interested
in quantum mechanics.
When I was in high school,
I heard about the fact that
you know, particles can
interfere like waves and so on.
And so it just blew my mind,
so I knew I wanted to study
quantum mechanics further.
And then when I came to grad school,
I was very intrigued by the
fact that you could compute
using the principles of quantum mechanics.
You can imagine building
an operating system
based on quantum mechanics.
So that was just completely bizarre
and I just wanted to be a
part of this mysterious field.
And so that's how my journey started.
And now I just started my group last year.
I have two graduate students, one postdoc,
and two new graduate students are coming.
They're joining us this fall.
And I also have an undergrad
working with the team.
So that's my story.
- Perfect.
Thank you very much.
And then so this is...
So Linran and Shruti can tell us
about their experience as
a recent faculty member.
And then we also wanted
to include Anderson Brito
who is the co-chair of the
Yale Postdoctoral Association.
And so you can introduce yourself please.
- Yeah. So thank you very
much for having me here today.
It's really a pleasure to be here
sharing a little bit of my
experience as a postdoc.
I am not a quantum scientist let's say.
I am a biologist with
a master's in virology
and a PhD in computational biology.
So I have this very
interdisciplinary sort of background.
And as was just said by...
Sorry.
By Florian.
I am here basically representing
the Yale Postdoctoral Association
as one of the co-chairs currently.
And I got invited by Florian,
which was one
of our co-chairs in the past
and a founder member of
this Yale association.
And it's really nice to be here today
to share a little bit of my
experience as a postdoc at Yale.
Thank you.
- Thank you very much.
And yes.
Never underestimate the
power of networking,
because if I haven't met
you, I will reach out to you.
And we can do great things.
Okay. Let's kickstart this meeting.
And we're gonna answer
some of the questions.
And so I think the first
one that comes in mind
when we think about faculty
member is the stress
as postdocs and as senior grad students
of how can I find a faculty position?
And what are the steps?
And so can I have either Shruti or Linran
go over the process of
what are all the steps
that you took to get this position?
And you can answer that from any angle
that you feel would be helpful.
Maybe we can start by Shruti.
- Okay.
So for me, the process was
you basically care about...
You have to keep an eye...
So for me, I kind of was
looking where I wanted to be.
And so I kept an eye on the hiring market
in those particular universities.
And also my colleagues
knew that I was looking
so they would forward me any announcements
made about hiring at their university.
So you basically...
You can be proactive in looking
for open positions at places,
or you can obviously get help
from your colleagues about this.
And once you, you know,
usually the process starts
around September, October.
You kind of know where you
want to go by September,
and then the deadlines
for applications are
around October/December,
sometimes late December.
So you basically prepare
your application process,
which is like your CV.
You have to write a research statement.
Basically, in your research statement,
you want to convey the things
that you want to do in
the next five years or so
in your research group.
And then you have to write
a teaching statement.
Sometimes you have to
write diversity statements.
And then there's blank;
you just have to wait.
After all the applications are sent,
then you just have to wait and have faith
that somebody has actually
found your application
and is reading it.
And eventually you will hear from places.
Sometimes they call you to
have like a phone interview,
which is usually like maybe 30 minutes.
Sometimes it's even shorter.
And then if you go through that,
then they'll call for
in-person interviews.
So I had, in some cases,
both phone interviews
and in-person interviews.
And then again there is a blank.
You wait for a long time to hear back
and sometimes you have to ping them
and be like, "Hey, where is
the application process at?"
So that was my overall experience.
Maybe I missed something.
Lin, do you wanna add in?
- Yeah. So I think you probably
covered all the aspects
of the faculty search,
but my experience is a
little bit different.
I mean, Florian and
Anderson, and also Shruti,
you mentioned that networking
is actually quite important.
So the reason why I got
this position is actually
I was quite lucky that
when I was a postdoc...
So I was not prepared for a
faculty position at that time.
And I was approached by some colleague
that I knew when I was a graduate student.
And also I got some information
from my advisors and so,
"Okay. There's a faculty position.
I think that can fit you well.
And why don't you apply?"
And then I applied, and
that's how I got it.
And the preparation is quite similar.
So we need to prepare the CV.
You write the research statement
and the teaching statement,
diversity statement
and all kinds of stuff.
And also normally we need
to give like two talks.
One is the research talk about your work.
One is like named job talk to
present your research ideas
for your future group.
And I think most of
them are very important.
And the research talk
presents your capability
and the job talk
will show how you will lead the group
as an independent researcher.
I think that's also very
important, especially now.
I believe most universities
when they post the faculty position
they kind of have a idea
what kind of background,
what kind of person they are looking for.
So if your...
So if your future plan matches their idea,
I think that will be very helpful.
Yeah.
- How many applications...?
Can you give I guess a ratio of like
how many applications did you send?
How many responses did you get?
Because we always hear like
there's more production of PhDs
than positions available.
Which I think in quantum is
we are in a weird bubble these days.
I calculated that last year
there was 161 faculty positions open
in the US in quantum.
So it's quite a lot for the field.
It's a very hot topic,
but can you give us a ratio
of how many interview...?
Or like how many positions
did you interview for
and like how many offer...?
You can also keep that confidential.
Just give us like a broad idea
if you don't want to disclose
any of the other things.
So for me-
- [Linran] I...
- Sorry. No, go ahead Lin.
- No. Shruti, I think you can go ahead,
because my case is not common.
- Right. So for me,
I actually went to the job market twice.
One was 2018/2019 round
and then the other one
was 2019/2020 round.
So in the first round when I applied,
there were much fewer quantum jobs open.
I think there was...
I can't remember exactly how many,
but I think it was like around five-ish
or more universities that I applied to.
But none of them actually said
quantum information in it.
A lot of times they, you know,
send out a more general call.
So unless you have an inside idea
about what they're exactly
looking for, you don't know.
And I just wanted to get an experience
like get out the bad interviews before.
And so I was like, "I'm gonna
apply and see how it goes."
So in that round
I got one interview
and I didn't get a job.
Fortunately, I didn't get a job
so that I could get a job at Yale.
I'm very happy about that.
So in the second round, the
second year, the 2019/2020 year,
it was like amazing year for quantum.
As Florian said, there
was so many job openings
in our field.
And again I think I
applied to about eight,
nine universities or so.
I think I pretty much
got calls from everybody
except maybe two places.
And so it was a very stressful time,
'cause these job interviews take two days.
At least two or three days,
and then you're basically on
from 8:00 in the morning
to 8:00 in the night.
And yeah.
Like I said, I didn't get called
I think from two places, maybe three.
I got in-person interviews
and then I got offers from a few places.
Again, very lucky because I
know that during that time,
many people's offers were
withdrawn due to the pandemic.
Fortunately, that did not happen for me.
And that's when I landed at Yale.
- Yeah. My experience is not...
I mean, because I was
approached by some colleague.
So actually in 2018 I just applied here.
The only place I applied
is University of Arizona.
And luckily I got this position.
And after interview I
found this is a good place.
And I like the environment
and the research
and it has all the capabilities
that I need for my experiments.
So I just decided to join.
But from my experience
talking to other colleagues.
So...
The ratio is not good.
I mean, but it's not bad.
So I think probably on
average 1/3 will get a call.
And normally, so people,
university will invite like
around three to eight people
for onsite interview and they
will have a waiting list.
And if you are in the top three,
then I think you have
a pretty good chance.
Because I mean, normally like Shruti
you will get offers from several places
and you can only accept one.
So then for other places
if you decline that offer,
the second person on that list
will be offered the position.
Right?
So that's why Shruti mentioned
a lot of lengthy times.
So there'll be a lot of waiting time
during the faculty search.
- We have a question in the Q and A.
How long did it take for
you to prepare your research
and teaching statement?
So in preparing for the interviews
was any aspect of it
particularly challenging?
- So actually it's not long.
Normally just one page or
two pages, so not long.
I mean, but it takes a lot of time
to prepare that two-page
research statement, I believe.
And yeah, I think the key is that you need
to kind of make a connection
to your previous background,
but you need to find a new
angle to distinguish yourself.
I think that's probably
the most challenging part for myself.
- I was actually trying to
open up my research statement
to see how long it was,
but I was not fast enough.
For me, it was much longer.
- I think the question
is not about the size
of the research statement.
More like-
- How much time.
But I mean, it depends on also
how long you have to make it.
But I started preparing
my research statement
like over the summer,
'cause there's a lot of
thought that goes in there.
You have to show them that you are capable
of conducting new research and
support x graduate students
over the next five years.
So you have to show them that
you're capable of building
this whole research program.
You're not a postdoc anymore.
You're not just going to work
on this one little project,
you're gonna like lead a huge group.
So it takes a lot of time and effort.
And the teaching statement,
I spent much less time compared
to the research statement.
It is less important than...
Well, it's not less important,
it's equally important.
But it's usually only two pages,
so it goes a bit faster
then the research statement.
And then you have to write it early on
so that you have time to send it
to your colleagues, your advisor,
to get feedback from them.
And you know...
So basically I would say
by September and at
least it should be ready.
And you should already be getting feedback
from your colleagues.
- Thank you both.
Linran, you were talking about the fact
that your case was a little bit spacial,
because you sort of got picked up
by one of your colleagues.
And so I would like to
talk about the importance
of networking and
connection in this field.
How did you start building your network?
And then was he like your direct colleague
or was it like a more extended network
of researchers and fellow colleagues?
- So it's more extended network.
So because...
Quantum information is
special within the US.
Even though it's fastly growing,
but it's not a huge community.
So I guess most people know
each other in the field.
And in many cases,
maybe your advisor
collaborated on a project
with some professors
in other universities.
And if the other university
has a faculty opening,
they will reach out to your advisor
and also to some institutes like YQI.
So that's how I know this position.
- And so the reason I was asking
about networking is because
we in the US and I think in
many universities in the world
they're starting to build
a postdoctoral association
that helps with the networking.
And I would like to have a
little bit more information
about the postdoctoral
association with Anderson.
Can you talk a little bit about YPA
and your involvement with the association?
And while you talk I'll pull
up the website of the YPN.
- Yeah. Sure.
So this is quite a young association.
It was founded around seven years ago,
but since then it's been
growing quite a lot.
And in my view,
it has been transforming the experience
of postdocs and also associate
research scientists at Yale
by exactly favoring
networking, community building,
because these are one
of the main aims of the Yale
Postdoctoral Association.
In the YPA, we try
always to create a sense
of community engagement.
And also we always try to
allow a positive experience
at the university.
By, for example, organizing events
that are focused on
professional development
like seminars and also workshops.
But also social events,
which due to the pandemic will
actually stop for a while,
but we have still been
doing that via the internet
by using Zoom, for example.
And as Florian mentioned,
we should never underestimate
the power of networking,
because we may meet someone
from an unrelated field
and that person may
eventually be your connection
to someone in your field
by many other means;
because the person is
of the same nationality
of a researcher in your field.
There are many ways for
you to get connected
indirectly to someone in your field
by just meeting people
that are from other fields
that are let's say in the
same level of your career.
So I guess most of the people here
they are postdocs wanting to transition
into let's say academic career.
And by being a member of an association
there are many benefits.
I have just mentioned the
benefits related to networking,
which is one of those
let's say transferable
soft skills that we learn
via extracurricular activities,
because it's quite common
to see people focusing a lot
on researching skills.
And they sometimes forget
to strengthen a little bit
of other skills that they can also develop
like communication skills, networking,
leadership, time management,
project management.
All of these soft skills,
they are extremely necessary
for a successful career.
By being a member of an association,
you may gain some of these skills
by taking part of trainings
that such association may offer.
But if you also join as an
officer of that association,
you would also have opportunities
to strengthen such skills by
organizing events yourself,
by basically being the leader of a group
that has a project within the association
that has to be finished
within a defined time.
So all of these sort of
non-research activities,
they somehow teach us these skills
that are extremely helpful as
well in our academic career.
- Thank you very much.
And while you talk, I have
the website of the YPA
and on my screen.
So it's YPA.Yale.edu.
And the people in the
University of Arizona
also have their own website.
It's a similar association.
It's UApostdocs.weebly.com.
So you can go and check if
you can make new connection.
And I really agree that all
the work that you would do
if you're engaged in the leadership
of the association is
really, really helpful,
because you will start
building connection.
And also you will talk to leadership.
And it's easy to talk to people
on your level, your peers.
But it's also a different thing
to start having to ask things
to university leadership.
And I think it's a good
training also for the job talks,
because that's what you're gonna do.
You're gonna try to
convince above your grade.
And so I think it's a
pretty important thing.
And all the skills that you develop,
maybe we can go back to
Shruti and Linran talking
about what kind of other
skills do you need to have
to build a research group?
Because I think the more you go
into faculty, your job,
your job is not to do the
research as much as you do,
but like more managing
students and writing grants.
And you have a ton of serving
on panels at the universities
and other activities.
Can you talk a little bit more
about these extra activities
that grad students or postdocs
are not necessarily aware of?
Who wants to start?
- Yeah. I can just start it.
So yeah, you are right.
So it's very different to be
a PhD student or even postdoc
with being a faculty member.
So when I was a PhD student or postdoc,
we just need to focus
on one or two projects.
You just need to think about
how to do experiments better
and how to...
So how to finish the experiment.
But as a faculty member, I
think the biggest change is that
we don't really have a lot of time digging
into the details of other projects;
but on the other hand, we still need
to provide the big picture,
guide the students.
Especially when we start a new group.
So you are the knowledge
people in the group.
But on the other hand,
you have the least time
to dig into the details of the experiment.
I think that's the biggest
challenge I've faced.
So I think it's good.
It's better to balance the
time you work on proposals.
And also I still reserve
quite amount of time
doing experiments with the students,
at least for the first several years.
So therefore we can
accelerate the process.
But I think from...
It might be different
for a theoretical group.
So I think Shruti can say more about that.
But for experiment groups,
I think that I treat
myself as a half postdoc
at least for the first year.
So I still do a lot of like experiments.
I went into the clean room
with the students together.
Just help them do the fabrication,
do all the experiments.
But after three years
when the first student or
two students are well-trained
and they are good enough,
then I can spend more time on other stuff.
- Yeah. My sentiment is the same thing.
I always say that having a research group
is like having a startup.
And so basically whatever skills you need
to have a startup is what you need.
You need to be able to write
grants and bring in money.
You have to support your students.
You do get a startup package,
but that's not gonna last you forever.
And so the advice I was given was like,
save that money as much as possible
and just start writing
grants from day one,
which is what I did.
It's not only that.
As Linran also said, you have...
You have to prepare for your classes.
You have to prepare your new courses
that you're gonna teach,
you're gonna write grants,
so you don't yourself have
a lot of time for research.
So fortunately in my case
right in the beginning I had
a student who joined my group.
And she was pretty much at a good place.
But I started like a
quite different project
with different set of skillsets for her.
But she caught on really fast.
And so you need to be able
to identify, you know,
fast learners, I guess, and take them on.
And like right now she is
so good that I don't...
Basically she's training
the new students coming in.
So she is really, you know, the...
I would say I could not have...
I could take more students on without her.
I would not have the time to deal
with everybody at that level.
The other thing is again like
hiring postdocs and stuff.
You need to be able to judge them.
Like when you're interviewing them
and they come give talks to you,
you need to be able to
ask the right questions
and judge their capability.
Again hiring the right people
is going to change your life.
Like I hired a postdoc who's good.
I don't have to...
I just tell him like, we
are thinking about this.
Go figure it out, and he figures it out.
Right. So after a while you need it
to be a self-sustaining thing.
You cannot be person who's
actually writing codes,
or figuring out the math and stuff.
So these are the skillsets
that you don't necessarily
have as a postdoc,
but, you know, you need to develop.
- Is there any place that...?
Like how did you learn this skill?
Is it on the job?
Like first day it just
pushed you in the deep end.
It was like, okay.
You used to be a postdoc,
now you need to interview.
You need to write grants
and all these things.
Is there any resources
somewhere that helped you?
- I mean, I would say that ask...
Especially for grants.
I mean, like judging
somebody's capabilities,
how do you teach that?
You just like...
For me, it's like observe
when people are giving talks
and hear what your advisors are
saying about those speakers.
So you know.
Just catch on to things
that they're saying,
so that's how you learn.
Also, ask.
In my case as a postdoc,
I did not get a lot of chance
to be involved in grants.
I got a chance to be
involved in one grant,
but not you know...
Mostly for the scientific
part, not so much the writing.
But I would suggest that
if there's one thing
I could go back and redo again
would be ask my advisors,
can I be part of this grant?
So I learn the procedure and I get
some training of how these things work,
how you should present your
work, and so on and so forth.
- And speaking of grants,
I know a lot of universities
are giving classes
and resources, and there's grant writing.
Are you familiar with this, Anderson?
Do you want to talk about grant writing
that can be offered by
the postdoctoral affairs?
- Yeah. So one thing that
we have been working a lot
to make sure that we can offer
to our members is exactly
professional development events,
especially workshops.
We have been organizing.
We have been organizing workshops
about grant writing, article writing,
like scientific writing let's say.
And these are resources that
we can get out of Yale,
because Yale has many offices
that organizes different
sorts of workshops.
They are experts on those specific topics
and they can teach us,
but we have to somehow connect with them
and make such requests.
And this is something that
we are quite happy to see
that the YPA has been this very important
let's say facilitating.
That such training can
let's say be offered to our members.
Because definitely having a method
for writing grants and papers,
this makes a huge difference.
If you know how to structure things first
before writing that,
that can speed up the process.
And the final piece would look
much more cohesive, for example.
And these sort of trainings
we can get out of
let's say being a member of a
local association of postdocs.
And if such association does
not exist in your location,
you could even create your own
and start things from scratch.
- And this is what happened to me when...
So I did my PhD in France,
moved to Yale as a postdoc,
and then there was nobody to help.
And so a bunch of postdocs that we met
mostly European because of
the geographical connection.
We had this mini-network of foreigners
that met at the visa office at Yale;
got together and starting to say like,
"Hey, how can we help each other?"
Because I think that's also
the trick on everything.
You should network, you
should help everybody.
But I think if you find interests,
like if it's useful to you,
it's gonna be useful to others.
And so it's something that you can do.
And we're talking about
Yale and U of A a lot,
because this is our affiliations.
But this is valid for all
the universities in the US.
And also in most of the world
I think the universities
are starting to see
that people need resources similar to that
to prep them for the job market.
So they are offering workshops.
And now with the pandemic,
I think everybody shifted
to a virtual world.
And I'm pretty sure even
if your university doesn't
offer this kind of thing,
you can find virtual
workshops that you can attend,
or like view recordings online
like similar to one of these things.
So it's really something that
you should try to think about,
because in an ideal world
you are really good at what
you're doing in your research.
But the key way you're gonna be judged
for the applications and for these things
is gonna be everything else.
Can you be the extra...?
Are you the superstar in the field?
And I think that's what
people are looking in in universities.
And so that was one thing.
And also one thing that I want to add.
We're talking about how to get a job,
but there's also an interesting thing.
And I'm sorry I'm gonna bring
the mood a little bit down,
but not everybody's cut
out to be a faculty member.
And I think it's very
important to realize like,
do I want to do that
because it's the path that you want to do?
Or is it because your
advisor told you like,
"Hey, this is what you do.
You do a PhD, you do a postdoc,
and then you do a faculty."
And so there's also something
you need to think about:
is that the kind of job that I want?
And is it matching my skills
and what I want to do?
And there's a ton of
different jobs in quantum.
We're gonna cover in the
fall the startup world
and the industry world.
I think there's also more and more options
for a job in the quantum workforce.
And so if you're scared
about writing grants,
or if you're scared about
other the things that...
There's different possibilities,
so we'll work on these things.
We have another question in
the chat mostly for Shruti,
because you went to two
different rounds of application.
They wanted to know, is
it better to wait a turn?
Like if you apply and then get a position
that you could do better next time.
Is it worth taking it?
Or would it look bad similar
to like burning bridges
if you decide to refuse this
and then try to get a
better option next year?
What's your take on that?
- I think as long as, I don't know,
you don't hit somebody over there
you're not gonna like burn any bridges.
Like when you...
If you're called for an interview
and you're not the first choice
or not one of the top three choices,
it doesn't mean that you are bad
or you don't have the skills.
It's just that you're not right now a fit
for the particular direction
that the university is looking at.
So to me,
it doesn't show anything negative.
That being said, I would say
strike when the iron is hot.
There are some key papers
that you're going to
publish in your career.
When those hot papers come
out, apply for a position.
You need to be out there.
And that's when you're
gonna be more popular.
Don't wait for like two more years,
because after two more
years you may not have
another hot paper again.
And then your chances are gonna be lower.
- You're talking about hot paper.
Can you both talk about
how can you strengthen your application?
Do you need to have teaching experience?
Do you need to have grants?
What are the things you can
do as senior grad students
or as a postdoc to have
a really strong case
for the university to hire you?
- Yeah. So I think of
course, first of all,
we need to have a good
research background.
So that's the foundation
for everything I believe.
And the on top of that,
I think that if you have some
experience getting some grants
as PhD students or postdocs,
I think that will add points to it.
But I believe in terms of
in the community of quantum information,
I think there are not many chances
for postdocs to write grants, I believe.
Because I know that for
biology and medical schools
postdocs can't apply for grants.
But that's not very common
in quantum information area.
Yeah.
But on the other hand, if you can
at least direct something
or participant in some grant preparation,
I think that would be very helpful.
- Yeah.
I did not have any grants.
I've never applied for a grant.
I didn't get any awards
or anything like that
when I was a grad student or
early in my postdoc career.
You have to basically show that,
a, the research you're doing is important.
It's changing the direction of something,
whatever field you're in.
Not only that, you can
pump out that new research
for the next however many years.
And you also have to
establish your independence
from your advisor.
That was the one important
advice that I was given.
As a postdoc, there's not a...
Again it depends upon your situation.
You may have an opportunity
to do it, you may not.
Experimentalist, it's a little bit hard,
because it's the lab
that your advisor has.
So you basically do what's
in the lab pretty much.
For a theorist it's a little bit easier.
You can come up...
All you need is a paper and pen,
so you can do whatever
the heck you want to.
So in my case, it was you know...
I was able to demonstrate that my research
is different and
different from my advisor,
and that I'll be able to
continue that research
into the future.
So that's what I would say is important.
- And I would also say that
maybe applying for a fellowship
to be a postdoctoral fellow.
It's a process that would
somehow also teach us
how to write a grant,
because it's a short version of a grant
that you have to think about
how that project will be developed.
What are the scope, objectives?
Then you go through a
process of selection.
So this whole experience somehow
it starts to teach us
how to write a grant.
And if we get that,
that is something that is quite valuable.
It's seen as a sign of independence.
That you are able to search for a grant
and eventually get approval.
So I would definitely advise
like trying to apply for a fellowship.
It's something that would
definitely advance your abilities
and will give you much
better chances to get hired.
- Just one more thing that I
forgot to say earlier was also
try to give as many talks as possible,
including try to get invited talks.
They do look at that.
They want to know that
your research is important.
That people will actually request
for you to come and talk about your work
and rather than you just
applying to talk somewhere.
- And regarding fellowship,
there's more and more
big centers, institute,
and industry providing
postdoctoral fellowship.
I know YQI has the YQI fellowships
that actually are open right now.
So you can apply.
You have until November 15.
I'm just putting it out
there if you're interested.
But there's also a ton of
similar programs everywhere.
So these are like,
we call them like gold star postdocs.
It's similar to your regular postdoc,
but they have a little bit of shine on it.
So that might help you.
It's not gonna do everything,
but it might like shine a little bit
of varnish in your application.
That's also something you can do
that might help a little bit.
So looking at the last
few questions that I have.
We're getting inviting talks.
Like how do you proceed for that?
Like is it similar to...?
We have a question in the
chat about visiting scholars
and visiting researcher during
PhD and during postdocs.
Is that something that
you've done in the past?
Or is it something that we
haven't seen, you haven't done?
- I personally haven't done any
like visiting scholars or
researchers and in places.
So the reason is because
I'm an experimentalist.
Specifically I need to focus
on my experiments, projects.
And we have already built up
that capability in my own group.
So there's no point for
me to visit another group.
But I do see a lot of theorists
visiting other institutes.
Especially in many cases,
I find it fruitful to have
a theoretical researcher
to visit experiment group.
And in many cases I find that
discussion is very helpful.
- Thank you.
And then I think one last thing
that I want to talk about.
There was a point about Shruti.
I'm gonna put the slide up.
There's the CM/AMO Rumor Mill website
that has a ton of information
about all the job postings.
Did any of you use it
for your applications?
So like were looking at
the different openings.
Or is it something that just a good thing
to see the short list?
- This is actually my first
time to know this website.
- Really?
Well, for me, I was told that this is
where you basically live
during the application process.
But no. I did visit this website
quite frequently to look for
new positions that are open
and which I might not
have heard about before.
- Right. So actually as
you look for positions,
I do realize that there's
no centralized websites
or good place that can have
all the posted positions.
So actually, Florian,
I'm a little bit curious
that you mentioned that you said
there was 161 positions last year.
I'm wondering how did you get that number?
- So I went through actually this website.
They have a list of everything.
So this one, the new posting
for 2021 have only two
job postings right now.
But if you go to the archive,
you have all the list.
It's an endless list of scroll through.
It doesn't mean that
there was 160 positions.
It just meant that
there was some openings.
And I don't know if the
university actually went through
because of the pandemic
and the job shortage.
Or like the freezing of the fundings.
But that's something that...
This is where I found all the information.
And then I was also cross-posting,
like cross-referencing
with all the job postings
that are received,
because we have an excellent
announcement section
on our website.
I often get a ton of job
postings from the other centers.
Also that is something
like if you look for jobs,
that's something that
you can do looking at
your university listing
or your department.
They might have a section.
Usually the chair of your department
or your PIs receive a ton,
a ton of open positions.
You might be able to ask them,
so like, "Hey, if you see
anything, just forward the email."
Because they usually don't
have time to read it,
but if they know that you're looking...
If you tell them, "Hey,
I'm considering..."
I think communication with
your advisor is really key.
I've seen people in conferences posting
at the end of their talk:
hey, I'm looking for position.
I'm looking for jobs.
Like it's really important to communicate
what you want to do.
Online presence is more
and more important,
so if you have a website,
if you have a Twitter.
Like the quantum Twitter is very active.
It's a little bit so that you have
everybody on social
media working on like...
Keep working outside of
your work on social media.
But it has been pretty good resources
to find a job application for that.
- If I can also add something
on this topic of job posting.
And this has something to do with
what Florian has just mentioned.
Twitter.
It's a great resource of
information about job postings.
All the time I saw like advertisements
about job postings on my area.
I'm not in the right moment
to apply for them yet.
But if I wanted so...
Just last week I saw
one amazing job posting
that was just passing through my timeline.
And also Twitter is basically
great for networking as well.
I found my post doctoral
position through Twitter
in a process of serendipity
by just clicking, clicking.
And then suddenly I
found this job posting.
One thing that I always recommend.
Join Twitter and try to
use that professionally
by having your bio describing who you are,
where you went in terms
of your background.
And start following people in your field,
because eventually you may see
on their profile a job posting
that you would never find by googling
or by looking at mailing lists;
because on Twitter you may by
chance find such information
that are quite useful.
And such information comes from networking
in this online environment.
- Thank you very much for
that comment or insight.
We're almost out of time.
So what I propose is we can go around
and have like maybe the
last advice of the hour.
We can do a round, and then I'll show you
the upcoming events in this series.
So like 30 seconds of
wisdom from all of you.
Like what's the best thing you can do
or maybe just best wishes, I guess.
Who wants to start?
Shruti, you wanna go?
- Oh. I didn't think about this before.
No. Just I don't have much advice,
but I just want to say that
when I was a postdoc I was very unsure
about being an assistant,
being a professor.
Like I knew I wanted to be that,
but I wasn't very
confident or I wasn't sure
whether I was gonna get the
position I wanted or not.
I would just say, don't be afraid.
Put yourself out there.
If you're not gonna take risks,
you're gonna get any reward.
So just try it.
If that's something that you
wanna do, don't worry about
whether you think you're
good or bad, or whatever.
Just give it a shot.
- Linran, do you want to
do last few words for this?
- Yeah.
I think as Shruti mentioned
that there are a lot of uncertainties
when finding a faculty position.
My advice is that, well...
So we should still keep
the focus on your research
while you are searching for a position.
So of course in a good situation
you'll find a position.
And you are ready to move
to start your new group.
But in a bad case, so you
should continue your work
and prepare for the next round.
So my suggestion is that keep going,
continue with your current research work.
And focus on that while you are applying
for a faculty position.
Thanks.
- Thank you very much all
for taking the time to talk to us.
Before we wrap up this event,
I would like to point out a few events
that might be helpful.
The C2QA which is the Co-design Center
for Quantum Advantage,
which is one of the national hubs
that the government
put in place in the US.
This one is the one that Yale is part of.
Out of Brookhaven National
Labs in Long Island
is hosting a quantum career
fair on September 22nd.
So if you're interested,
go on their website and check it out.
And then the next event for us.
So we talked about a ton of different ways
to get involved in the quantum field
as either studying it in college,
doing a PhD in grad school.
We've talked about how to put
all the chances behind you
to become a faculty member.
We're gonna have two more
events in this series.
One in October to prepare for startup.
The event will be on October 27
at the same time on Friday at 4:00 p.m.
And then we'll have one
later on on industry jobs.
We should have in the span
of the full year covered
all of the possibilities that you can do.
And all the videos of
these events are available
on YouTube on our website.
So if you go on
QuantumInstitute.Yale.edu/videos,
you should be able to
see all of these events.
Thank you all for joining us.
I really appreciate your time and insight.
And I hope you have really
prosperity in your research groups.
And Anderson, thank you
so much for joining us
and giving us all this
insight about the YPA.
Thank you for attending
and have a good night.
Thank you, Florian.
- Thank you very much.
- [Florian] Bye.